optimal at this altitude I can run flat
out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking and I also the personal
question now is see I'm a cybernetic
organism living tissue over metal
endoskeleton this episode is brought to
you by headspace more than 80% of the
people I have interviewed world-class
performers across the military
entertainment sports and beyond all have
some type of meditative practice I tried
for years and years and failed miserably
the key is making it simple and you can
dramatically improve your life in just
10 minutes a day and technology can help
you this change comes through guided
meditation and headspace is by far the
most popular app for this purpose more
than four million users it's meditation
made simple so what I recommend is that
you take this practice meditation which
is rooted in thousands of years of
tradition supported by thousands of
scientific studies and try it for 10
minutes a day for 10 days that's all you
need to do you could also check out the
founder and II put it Combs TED talk
which has more than 5.5 million views
his last name is PUD di Co MBE if you
want to look that up but otherwise
download the free headspace app I have
it on my phone and begin there take ten
program for ten days of guided
meditation completely free ten minutes a
day that's all it takes
you should give it a shot headspace calm
forward-slash Tim just go to headspace
calm forward-slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it investing service
led by technologists from places like
Apple and world-famous investors it has
exploded in popularity in the last two
years and they now have more than two
and a half billion dollars under
management in fact some of my very good
friends investors in Silicon Valley have
millions of their own money in
wealthfront so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront dot-com forward
slash tim take the risk assessment quiz
which only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why the value of wealth front is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint and little things that you may
or may not be familiar with like
automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than 10 asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealthfront
as I mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free if you use my link wealthfront comm
forward slash tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when i have a sponsor on this
show is because i use them and recommend
them in this case it's a little
different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener
you'll get fifteen thousand dollars
managed for free if you decide to open
an account but just start with seeing
the portfolio that they would suggest
for you take two minutes fill out their
questionnaire at wealthfront dot-com
forward slash Tim it's fast it's free
there's no downside that I can think of
greetings earthlings this is tim ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
tim ferriss show where it is always or I
should say usually my job to deconstruct
world-class performers to tease out the
habits routines tools favourite
practices workouts books whatever it
might be that they use that you can test
that you can experiment with in your own
life and this episode is going to be a
round 2 highly anticipated with none
other than Jaco will ink and Jaco did
his first interview with me which was
the first interview he ever did and it
took the internet by storm Jocko willing
at Jocko willing on Twitter Jocko
podcast calm is one of the scariest
human beings imaginable lean 230 pounds
black belt Brazilian Jujitsu used to tap
out 20 Navy SEALs per workout he is an
intimidating and very intelligent person
I've spent more time with him and the
more time that I spend with him the more
impressive he is to me he spent 20 years
in the u.s. Navy and commanded SEAL team
3 is task unit bruiser the most highly
decorated special operations unit from
the Iraq war upon returning the u.s.
Jacko served as the officer in charge of
training for all West Coast SEAL Teams
designing and implementing some of the
most challenging and realistic and
perhaps psychotic competitor aning in
the world his words not mine after
retiring from the Navy he co-founded
exelon front I think I'm getting the
pronunciation right leadership and
management consulting company and
authored the number one New York Times
bestseller which was introduced in a way
on my podcast extreme ownership which
many of you have read he now discusses
war leadership business
jujitsu life you name it in his top
rated podcast also to some really really
good book reviews or commentary on
things that are dark in some cases like
the My Lai massacre Jocko podcast check
it out
and without further ado we are going to
tackle or I should say Jocko is going to
tackle your most common most burning
questions and he doesn't dodge
so I hope you enjoy it as much as I did
jakka willing hey thanks Tim thanks for
having me on appreciate it and thanks
everybody that submitted questions I'm
gonna try and get to as many as I can
here all right the first one is from a
guy by the name of Jeffrey McLeod and
the question is how do you shut internal
doubt down and negative chatter out of
your head during critical must-do
moments how do you change emotional
negative focus States when something or
someone knocks you off focus first of
all internal doubt is not necessarily a
bad thing and I've said this before
about fear of failure because internal
doubt that first of all that's a form of
humility and obviously humility is a
good thing and that internal doubt and
that fear of failure is the thing that
the thing that keeps you up at night
preparing that's the thing that's not
gonna let you cut corners it's the thing
it's that little voice that little voice
inside your head that's whispering
rehearse again practice again do it
again over and over again and that's the
voice that says to do everything you can
to be ready
so I'm I'm okay with that I'm okay with
that little internal doubt but this
doesn't mean that you lack confidence I
mean as a matter of fact when you when
you prepare correctly it when you have
the discipline to prepare correctly then
you will have confidence and that is
definitely a good feeling to have
because the all that negative chatter
that you're talking about here here's
the deal with that every repetition of
practice that you do every iteration of
rehearsal that you complete every bit of
study that you do and every drill that
you do all that all that preparation is
going to drown out the negative chatter
so you got to prepare now then we get to
this piece here it was how do you change
emotional negative focus states when
something or someone knocks you off
focus well I think this is where it's
important to have that ability to detach
and it isn't like you're gonna
completely detach and not feel those
things at all not like you're gonna make
those emotions disappear and it's not
even like you'd want them to disappear
completely because those things are
normal but what you have to do when you
detach is it's going to allow you to to
see those emotions or that negative
focus and see it from a distance and
then understand that they are there and
then make sure that they don't overwhelm
you and so like in your head you're
gonna be saying oh okay I see that
that's that's some nervousness sneaking
up on me got it
that's a good sign because that means my
mind is focused and I'm in the game okay
what's next oh oh oh got some some
negative thoughts okay well those are
normal and I gotta know that things are
going to go bad and that's fine how bad
can they go what's a worst-case scenario
worst-case scenario is not that big of a
deal I know I can handle the worst-case
scenario if it happens so what else what
else is in my mind what else negative
thought am I having what about those
things that you can't control the things
that you can't control and you're
worried about those things well you know
what I can't control them so if I can't
control them why worry about them
because the energy that you put into
worrying about them actually cost you
your effectiveness it's going to cut
into the energy you should be putting
towards achieving what you're trying to
achieve so focus on the things that you
can control and make the things that you
can control 100% and and the bottom line
with all this with these negative
thoughts if if I give everything I can
if I prepare as hard as I can if I
practice much I can if I do have a
rehearsal and I do everything I can and
I still come up short good I'm going to
learn from it I'm going to get better so
that's what I'm gonna do with internal
doubt I'm okay with it
negative chatter I'm gonna utilize it
and I'm just gonna detach a little bit
to make sure I don't get drowned out in
these emotional situations so just get
your head in the game and get after it
done okay next question next question
comes from will we'll get drawn and he
says how does his love of love and study
of literature influences leadership
skills what were some of the best books
for developing his knowledge of
leadership okay so the thing that I look
for when I'm reading and when I'm
reading um that includes everything
let's just talk about everything here
books history books literature even
poetry and even like song lyrics
everything I'm trying to learn about
human nature that's what I'm looking for
and of course since since combat is like
life amplify amplified and intensified
which is something we say all the time a
lot of times the books that are about
war give some of the best insight into
human nature you know you're talking
about the stress and the fear and the
courage and the breaking points and the
darkness of humanity and also the beauty
of humanity and all those can be seen in
their most extreme and in their most
obvious form in war and so a lot of
books that I do read are about war and I
have a ton of them and again they're not
so much leadership books by definition
as a matter of fact I don't even know if
I have any coal on
leadership books but I got a ton of
books that have taught me a ton about
leadership and first and foremost and I
said this on when I was on Tim's podcast
for the first time about faced by
colonel david hackworth it's it's the
only book I've ever actually given to
anyone and it's a big book and people
people that have bought it people on
Twitter that have gone out and bought a
book it's a 700 page book it is a big
book it spans from the tail end of World
War 2 through Korea Vietnam and a little
bit of post Vietnam and it's a big book
it's a career military guy and Colonel
Hackworth was just just a just an
incredible leader and you don't just get
from that from the book when you when
you learn about hackworth if you start
digging in and hearing what other
people's opinions are people loved him
especially the people that worked for
him loved him now obviously he had some
trouble up the chain of command at
certain points but that's that's part of
me that's part of being a dynamic leader
I guess and he held his ground on some
stuff so that book is just incredible
book and it's got lessons learned on
every page and you know I I cover most
of the books that I've read that I've
had a huge impact on me I'm covering
them up on my podcast
so books like like with the old breed by
Eugene sled sledge and Beyond Band of
Brothers by dick winners I remember the
last war by a guy named Bob Hoffman
another book by Hackworth called steal
my soldier's heart book called platoon
leader by Jim McDonough and another good
one another good Vietnam one the killing
zone by Frederick Downes in those books
I mean you could just go on and on and
again it's not always clear that oh
here's the leadership principle here's
what you should be doing
no it's not always clear like that but
when you when you understand what people
are going through emotionally and you
start to get a glimpse at human nature
and how people react in certain
situations and how their egos flare up
that's what makes these books good
because it gives you something to as it
gives you a frame of reference and I'm
still reading all the time
and I'm still learning still trying to
get better and still trying to take what
other people been through how they
handled it what they did right what they
did wrong mistakes they made that's what
I'm trying to do and actually I think
that's actually one of the things that
has made my my podcast become popular is
because I look at these other people's
experiences and I compared them with
mine and it's just it's it's always I'm
always learning and I think that when
you look at I talk about the mistakes
that I made and even even the book that
I wrote with life is it certainly isn't
any kind of a chronicling of our
triumphs I mean if anything it's the
opposite in many cases because all much
of the book is is about mistakes that we
made and it's about things that we could
have done better and lessons that we
learned and I think that's why I think
it's why it's why that book extreme
ownership is done well because it's
something you can learn from and and I
think people learn the most myself
included when you fail so read and read
and read some more and pay attention to
in my mind pay pay pay attention to the
details not again not just the
leadership but the human the human
element the human interaction the
glimpses into the the core of human
nature in the bigger bank you build of
experiencing how humans react the more
you know and then you take that and you
overlay the experiences you read about
over what's happening in your world and
that's I think a key point is to
actually think about how what you're
reading applies to what's happening in
your world and then you start to pay
attention to human nature in your world
and see that there's some underlying
some underlying force that makes people
do what they do and the better you can
understand that force of human nature
the better off you're going to be and
the better job you're going to do as a
leader so keep reading next up I got a
guy here named Kip mackaninee what would
his advice be to young men and women who
are no longer in the military but are
still looking to contribute also has he
considered running for any public office
position so if if you were in the
military and you got out either you
retired or you just did your time and
you got out you know go out and put
those skills that you got from the
military put those skills to work of the
discipline the work ethic the leadership
the the ability to a tad to detach the
ability to to instruct and there are
industries I'm telling you I work with
businesses all the time now and there
are industries that need you in fact I
will tell you that most industries need
people like you people like veterans and
so find an industry that that you're
interested in and then go get busy and
go get after it and make that your next
mission and if there's no industries
that industry interests you which is
kind of hard to believe that you'd have
no interest but if you don't or if
you're looking for something maybe that
has more kind of internal meaning then
go out and find a really good nonprofit
organization that needs help because
again they need the same thing they need
people they need leaders they need
people that are disciplined they need
people that can solve problems they need
people with the skills that you have the
skills that you learned in the military
so go and put those to work
and I will tell you that there's did you
know America as a whole needs leadership
and so there's no reason that veterans
like I said who who have a lot of those
skills from being in the military and
from being deployed overseas there's no
reason that veterans shouldn't make up a
big portion of leaders in the civilian
sector so step up and get after not say
a one one last thing about that is
there's a lot of companies and I work
again I work with all kinds of different
companies all kinds of companies want to
hire veterans they they recognize that
their success is based on the freedoms
that they have so they want to pay back
somehow and so that'll many many
companies are anxious and eager to hire
veterans so get out there find what
you're interested in and make it happen
now the other part of this question as
far as running for political office and
I say this all the time this is kind of
a canned answer I don't think I have the
stomach for it the corruption and the
sly meanness of the whole thing not to
mention just the complete loss of
privacy and the scheduling in the whole
meeting of people that I don't like and
having to be civil to them whole thing
it's it's like I said I don't I don't
think I have the stomach for it and I
mean I guess that perhaps at some point
that feeling could be over written if
things got bad enough you know I would
definitely have a sense of duty in and
I'm a very patriotic person and if the
nation truly needed me then of course I
would serve but until that time I'm
gonna go ahead and just steer clear of
any political endeavors okay the next
question is from Adrian Marquez and it
says any considerations regarding being
a pawn of thee and he says industrial
military conflicts and maybe he means
military industrial complex I'm not sure
but we'll go with it so again any
considerations regarding being a pawn of
the industrial military conflicts to
serve the economic interests of US
corporations would he do it all over
again the next part of the question is
what's next make up another excuse
invade an African nation for resources
so
but of course when you are serving in
the US military
you are you are serving at least you
should be serving the interests of the
United States of America absolutely and
embedded in those interests there are
absolutely the economic interests of
American corporations and obviously the
economic power of the United States is a
key component of America's power and
influence in the world in so yeah when
you are a military member you could be
considered a pawn in the military
machine but the
act in a matter is I am I'm actually
honored to have served as a so-called
pawn pawn in that system and I will tell
you this and I've said this before
America is is far from perfect then we
have committed some Horrors in our
history and even today we make mistakes
in the world but when you travel the
world and you see how much of the rest
of the world lives how much they live in
disarray then you see the oppression and
you see the poverty and you see the
corruption and you see the abject
violations of basic human rights then
you realize how blessed or lucky or or
maybe even spoiled we are to live in
America and just to start let's just
start with let's start with potable tap
water drinking water that we just in
America we just have that here we have
it everywhere any home any apartment
even the prisons you turn on the tap
then you get good clean disease-free
drinking water and that is not the norm
in the rest of the world and on top of
that we have power got electricity going
into just about every home
that means just about every home has
heat in the wintertime and they have air
conditioning in the summertime and let's
just take it a little bit further that
what about the access to the Internet
the access to the internet here is
widespread there's like something like
70% of the adults in America have a
smartphone 70% so 70% so you can gain
access to knowledge here unlike any
other time in human history
and our our healthcare system but I know
it's not perfect but I'll tell you what
if you view our healthcare system from a
third-world hospital which often don't
even have the simplest of medical gear
you'd realize it might not be perfect
but it's pretty damn good and then
beyond that it's just but like let's
look at the food that's available never
mind
starvation and malnutrition our issue in
America is actually too much food then
and much of the world still has people
literally starving to death in America
offers an amazing opportunity to build
and to create in to be what you want to
be and to be who you want to be unlike
anywhere else in the world the ability
to pursue happiness
happiness
and and all those things all of it is
possible because of the unbridled
individual freedom that America offers
and you know what else
it's also possible because of industry
because of the incredible corporations
and businesses and individuals because
of people that took advantage of that
freedom and work their asses off to
build this nation so to have been a pawn
in that to have done my small share of
work to allow this beacon of light and
of hope and of freedom to continue
I'm I'm honored that I had the chance
and would I do it all again you're damn
right I would without question and then
there's another piece to this question
from mr. Marquez it says what's next
make up another excuse
invade an African country or an African
nation for resources well luckily we
have plenty of resources in our own
nation and luckily for the rest of the
world we have used those resources over
and over and over again not to take but
to give to give freedom to the slaves in
our own country to defeat and destroy
the brutal Nazi regime in Germany and
free the people of France and much of
Europe
we used our resources to defeat Imperial
Japan who is rampaging through Asia
invading and enslaving people with no
sign of stopping
we used our resources try and stop the
spread of communism in Asia and remember
that when I'm talking about resources
I'm not just talking about oil and steel
and wood I'm talking about blood I'm
talking about hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of American men
and women that gave their lives in the
cause of freedom
in in what what resources did we take
when we paid with our blood
we took nothing we took we took no
resources from the Germans we help them
rebuild into an economic superpower
we took no resources from the Japanese
we helped them rebuild into an economic
superpower the Japanese and the Germans
both have some of the highest standards
of living in the world we took nothing
from Korea or Vietnam and we took
nothing from Afghanistan and even Iraq
we took nothing and we only gave and we
continued to give in 2014 the US
government gave 43 billion dollars in
foreign aid and then there was another
25 billion on top of that from America
from religious organizations and
universities and colleges and private
voluntary organizations and even the big
American corporations now like I said
that doesn't mean that America is
perfect
far from it far from it and our past is
checkered with horrible mistakes that
we've made as a nation we've caused
massive hardships an incredible
suffering but we also evolved and we
have become a benevolent nation a good
nation and I know this because I saw it
with my own two eyes I saw the people of
Iraq who wanted freedom from the tyranny
of Saddam Hussein who then wanted
protection from the violent terrorist
extremists who cheered us in the streets
when we killed insurgents and who wept
when we left them and unfortunately who
were murdered when we abandoned them
because the politics in our own country
they wanted us in Iraq the people of
Iraq the normal citizens they wanted our
protection and they wanted our
positivity and they wanted freedom like
much of the world does
and I was honored to have done my small
part to provide the opportunity for
freedom around the world and to protect
that precious freedom which is all too
often taken for granted here at home now
the next question the next question is
from someone named Don Ryan and he says
what's the hardest thing you've ever
gone through and what do you foresee as
the toughest thing on the horizon ill
endure
well
the hardest thing I've ever gone through
is losing my men in combat
and I say my men but they weren't my men
they were my friends and they were my
brothers
barring the loss of any members of my
direct family I don't think I'll ever
have to endure anything is soul-crushing
and devastating as losing my friends in
combat
you
next question this is from Nathan Lowe
what advice would you give an active
duty Navy SEAL or other military
personnel following the election if
Hillary is elected or if Trump is
elected well the fact the matter is
either Hillary or Trump will be elected
and the seals just like the rest of the
military will do what the military
always does and what they are sworn to
do and if you don't know what that is I
wrote down here the oath of enlistment
and I'll read it to you so you know what
it's what it says it says I do solemnly
swear that I will support and defend the
Constitution of the United States
against all enemies foreign and domestic
that I will bear true faith and
allegiance to the same and that I will
obey the orders of the President of the
United States and the orders of the
officers appointed over me according to
the regulations and the Uniform Code of
Military Justice so help me God so
that's the that's the oath that you
swear to when you join the military
you're going to obey those orders now
there is a little bit of a caveat and
that is in the Uniform Code of Military
Justice article 92 because it gets a
little bit more specific the article is
entitled failure to obey order or
regulation any person subject to this
chapter who number one violates or fails
to obey any lawful General Order
regulation to having knowledge of any
other lawful order issued by any member
of the Armed Forces which it is his duty
to obey fails to obey the order or his
derelict in the performance of his
duties shall be punished as
court-martial may direct so
the key word there is lawful order and
they made this perfectly clear during
the Nuremberg trials when the Nazi war
criminals claimed that they were just
following orders well in America that
doesn't cut it they have to be lawful
orders so regardless if Hillary Clinton
Donald Trump Obama Bush Nixon JFK or
Reagan it doesn't matter the military
will carry out the lawful orders of the
President and that's that next question
is from AJ Nystrom he says jaakko in
your book you speak about leadership
down and up the chain of command what in
your opinion and experience is the most
effective way to get leadership up the
chain to wake up and break the cycle of
rubber stamping ineffective practices
especially in law enforcement so
big question and I'll tell you first
things first the first thing you have to
do is be awesome that's what you got to
do seriously you got to be the best
police officer you can be and this goes
for any job you got to build the best
possible reputation and that means you
got to follow the rules even these
stupid inconsequential rules all of them
become the front-runner the top dog now
that doesn't mean you become the
loudmouth or the attention grabber but
you become the best legit police officer
you can possibly be and not only is this
going to build your reputation it's also
going to start to build your
relationships up the chain of command
and that's what you're trying to do
you're trying to build some
relationships here and the reason for
that is you need to build up the capital
the leadership capital the respect
capital so that you can ask some
legitimate questions and when the time
comes you go and you ask those questions
you know actually I I shouldn't say ask
questions because that gives them a
setup to provide you with the answers
and you already know the answers and you
don't agree with them so instead of
asking questions you take the reputation
that you built as a badass and you raise
points and when you raise points you
have solutions and you have solutions
that you've already socialized with the
team that you've already maybe even
tested or you've at least tried in other
words these are solutions that you know
are going to work and also pick your
battles pick your battles you got it
you're gonna have to eat some some
stupid stuff you're gonna do some lame
things but you got to pick your battles
you're not going to be able to change
everything so you got to pick the most
impactful issues to deal with and the
other ones just you support those and
you follow those like a good soldier
because
gives you more capital when you do raise
issues and and here's the other piece
when you raise issues up the chain of
command and this is a piece that people
mess this up all the time but when you
raise these points up the chain of
command and when you give the solutions
you have to do it from a point of
humility you can't be looking for the
credit you can't be looking for the
attaboy
you gotta come across and you've got it
not just come across you've gotta
actually be the humble person putting
forth some suggestions on how to do
things better NLT the the absolute black
belt move is when you get them to think
that it's their idea and that they came
up with it and that they've made up that
solution that's the ultimate black belt
move that's what you're looking to
achieve and that is how you win and that
is what I did with my career I worked as
hard as I could
I've followed everything they told me
but when something stood out I was able
to attack it address it and get the
problem solved or changed because I
built up that capital so build your
reputation build your relationships
build and vet your ideal and your
solution and then present it with
humility next question is from a guy
named Jonathan mule how would his
lifestyle of extreme discipline
translate to someone living a seemingly
unrelated life artists writers etc who
might find more productivity in pockets
of leisure or late at night now I would
argue that in these creative pursuits
you actually require even more
discipline and I would venture to guess
that the biggest reason that creative
types people in creative industry
is they with the reason that they don't
produce isn't because they don't have
vision and it's not because they don't
have talent I can just about guarantee
that in most cases it's a lack of
discipline I I'm always saying about
about working out I'm always saying that
the weights in the gym aren't going to
lift themselves you got to go lift them
well it's the same thing with a book
that book isn't gonna write itself you
got to write it the painting isn't going
to paint itself you got to paint it and
if you don't feel like writing or
drawing or painting or composing that
doesn't matter you do it anyways you you
grit down and you force the words onto
the paper or you force the brush onto
the paper or you force the notes out of
the instrument that's what you have to
do you have to make it happen
you have to force yourself to do it and
it's not always going to be good and you
might go back you might write a thousand
words and you might delete nine hundred
and fifty of them which you got fifty
words 50 words that you didn't have
before 50 words that you've created that
are solid
50 words closer to reaching your goal
as far as the time of day goes to me it
doesn't matter if you have some kind of
time of day where things seem to flow
better or whatever great take advantage
of it
I think I think people think because I
wake up early which I do that I believe
that everyone must do that but I'll say
it's it's that's not true it's it's the
principle it's it's about the principle
not about the specific time
and I got to throw a big butt on that
oh you can you can maybe work at
different times or maybe you stay up
later or maybe do better work at the two
o'clock in the morning or three o'clock
in the morning and so there's no way
you're getting up at 4:30 that's ok but
that doesn't mean oversleep and it
doesn't mean procrastinating it doesn't
mean hit the snooze button and it
doesn't mean staying up late diving into
the depths of useless YouTube videos and
claim that that is you being creative do
not lie to yourself there's a decent
chance that being creative is actually
being lazy in your mind do not do not
fall into that trap and I'll tell you
something else in order to gain skills
in order to master your craft any craft
you have to practice you have to
practice and practice and practice over
and over and over again and again and
that requires discipline that requires
discipline and that is another example
of how discipline will equal freedom the
more you practice your craft the better
you get at it the more freedom you have
to create so build the structure and
follow its put the discipline into your
life and the discipline it will increase
your skills and it will increase your
productivity and the discipline will
it'll set you free
now going on to the next question here
will the muster event oh sorry this is
from Marco Lopez Marco Lopez will the
muster event be a once-a-year thing only
after working with and training so many
different companies are there any
repeating patterns or common weaknesses
that business owners seem to need to
work on and it all
says will you please encourage Jocko to
do another Joe Rogan podcast so right on
Joe Joe knows I'm standing by we will
make it happen at some point yeah great
to be on his show we're just we're just
now getting around around to to with
with Tim so maybe Joe's around the
corner so we'll have to wait and see on
that one all right
to get to the question here for those of
you don't know the extreme ownership
muster is a leadership event that we're
having in in San Diego California I'm
doing it with with my business partner
the co-author of the book extreme
ownership late Bab and who's a seal that
I worked with for many years and my
brother and we're holding this thing in
San Diego California on October 20th and
21st and what the event is it's going to
be about combat leadership that's what
it's going to be about it's gonna be
about combat leadership and we're going
to teach the fundamental principles of
combat leadership and how to apply them
on the battlefield in business and in
life all all three
they're all you're going to see when you
come you're going to see how all three
of the applications are the same these
fundamental combat leadership principles
they don't change regardless of whether
you're out hunting down bad guys or
whether you're hunting for a sale they
don't change
and their response to the event has been
it's been awesome and we got a ton of
people coming to it which likely means
it looks like we're gonna do another
event possibly we got a carve the time
out of the schedule but it looks like
possibly the spring of 2017 likely going
to be somewhere on the East Coast if
it's gonna be somewhere on the East
Coast there's probably a pretty good
chance we'll be looking at New York City
not set in stone that we're going to do
it not set in stone when we're going to
do it we might wait another year I don't
know yet
it's just up in the air we have so much
stuff on our plates right now that we've
got to figure out if we can fit it in
but if we do it again maybe we'll head
out to the East Coast and you know New
York City get some now the next part of
this question is are there any repeating
patterns or common weaknesses that
business owners need to work on and the
answer is yes absolutely there are and
we see the same issues from company to
company and from leader to leader and
the same issues that we see in the
civilian sector are the same issues that
we saw while we were working with seal
platoons and Training seal tunes and the
core problems that we see are what we
wrote about in the book extreme
ownership that's one of the reasons we
wrote the book was because when we'd
work with these companies people would
say you have this stuff written down
anywhere and eventually we wrote it down
now what are some of those issues that
we run into
I mean you got departments and divisions
that aren't working together to cover
move you've got communications not being
made in a simple clear concise manner
you got either too much micromanagement
which leaves the troops to take no
initiative or you've got not enough
guidance and the troops now don't know
which direction to head into or you get
a company that's trying to take on too
many projects or too many initiatives at
the same time and they don't prioritize
and execute so they end up getting none
of them
done and and then the obviously the most
impactful one is when you have leaders
and team members taking ownership real
ownership
extreme ownership of everything in a
world to make sure that problems get
uncovered and owned and resolved because
if leaders and and members of the team
if they will take ownership of the
problems then guess who solves the
problems nobody so these are all again
these are our fundamental problems that
I saw when I was training SEAL platoons
and it's the same thing I see now it's
the same solutions that we apply to
these same problems learning the tactics
the fundamental tactics of leadership is
is what we get down to and we'll see at
the muster alright next this next
question is from Damien Hudson what does
jaakko struggle with or maybe better to
say what is he at work on he comes
across bulletproof and just pushes
through on everything would like to know
his method for identifying weaknesses
and putting structures in place to
resolve correct improve would like to
know his approach for his personal
challenges well first of all I can
assure you that I am far from
bulletproof and when you ask what I
struggle with I struggle with everything
I'm I'm not naturally gifted at pretty
much anything I'm not naturally strong
I'm not naturally fast though certainly
not the the sharpest tool in the shed
and so I constantly have to work on my
weaknesses and if you want to know what
my weaknesses are there's we don't have
enough time on the podcasts to list all
my weaknesses I mean it just that's the
way it is now as far as my method for
identifying weaknesses it's pretty
simple I'm constantly doing a
self-assessment and detaching
and looking at what I'm doing and what I
can do better and I ask people that are
close to me people that I trust ask them
if they have any feedback for me ask
them if there's anything I could do
better or where I can improve so that's
pretty simple do a self-assessment ask
other people and find out what your
weaknesses are what you could do better
and then the next part of the question
is what do I do to put structures in
place to resolve correct and improve
well I I just attack those problems
we weakness identified Roger attack the
weakness problem identified Roger attack
the problem and I'll tell you I'm not a
guy that spends a bunch of time over
analyzing or over planning or diving
deep into meditation on how I'm going to
attack a problem I simply attack the
problem now that doesn't mean that I
blindly attack and it doesn't mean that
I hold a course without checking on my
progress as I attack a problem I'm going
to continually assess and make sure that
I'm on the right course that I'm that
I'm headed in the right direction and in
making sure that it's the most efficient
path and I will absolutely change course
if I see something I can do better
and because I have that kind of attitude
it allows me to move quickly to execute
and then initiate change and alter the
course as I go if it's needed and it's
the same attitude that I had when I was
in the SEAL Teams I could be very
decisive very quickly because the
decisions themselves did not close my
mind the decisions did not close my mind
I would make a decision and I would
continue to reassess and readjust as
needed but also as we moved forward
towards a solution so you got a problem
step one identify the problem step two
attack it step three
reassess and adjust and keep attacking
get that thing solved
next question is from Chris Bell how to
stay motivated when every day is a
struggle to accomplish goals well I can
tell you very easily this is this isn't
about motivation then accomplishing your
goals is not about motivation it's about
discipline I already talked about that
once a day and I'll say it again I
probably talked about it more than less
talked about it a bunch I talked about
all the time
it is about discipline motivation is
fickle motivation comes and go I mean
you think about motivation you you simp
something as simply as being hungry can
SAP your motivation right that's
ridiculous you can't rely on that you
have o my blood sugar went down I'm not
motivated anymore oh I didn't get enough
caffeine I'm not motivated No wrong
answer
motivation is unreliable and when you're
counting on motivation to get your goals
accomplished you're likely going to fall
short so don't count on motivation count
on discipline you know what you have to
do go make yourself do it make yourself
do it everybody come on some kind of
magic pill or some Lifehacker something
that eliminates the need to do the work
well I will tell you what you need to do
the work you got to hold the line you
gotta make it happen yourself you have
to make it happen it's not going to
happen on its own you have to make it
happen so dig in find the discipline be
the discipline and accomplish the goals
period that's it
and our next question is from Austin
Farley and he said best advice to
today's active duty force regardless of
branch about career oversight
deployments differences between all
service members okay so the basic
question is best advice well the advice
besides be aggressive and stay safe
that's my number one I would tell you
for me the biggest component for success
in the military in my opinion is to do a
great job in whatever you're doing and I
know that sounds pretty obvious but I'll
tell you I saw a lot of guys over the
years were always looking for the next
ticket to punch or the next good deal or
the next job that they had to get to
take to make a promotion or whatever and
for me for the most part I just took
what they gave me and I did the best I
could at it and I'll tell you not only
did this keep the Navy happy because the
Navy you know they had a trooper that
was just getting after it it also kept
me happy cuz I wasn't sweating the
promotion or the evaluations or any of
the political stuff I was just I was it
getting after it to the best of my
ability and if you do that I'll I in my
opinion if you do that your career will
take care of itself you'll get the good
jobs because people will want you in
those good jobs and the other thing I
would say is this
big piece of being in the military is a
gut check this hard work it's either too
hot or too cold it's not enough food
it's not enough sleep it's not enough
water it's hurry-up-and-wait
it's planned four months to do nothing
and then don't plan it all to do
something four months and on top of all
that you throw the politics and the egos
and the bureaucracy and when you mix all
that together it can be pretty miserable
but I will tell you this all that misery
relish it relish every moment of it
because those hard things those rough
things those are a part of the
experience of the military and it's
experiences like that I promise you will
for some twisted reason you will miss
them when you leave so don't hate them
don't avoid them dive into them and kick
them in the ass with a smile on your
face because another thing is that
smiles contagious and you'll elevate the
morale of your whole unit when you wear
that smile so have fun and kick ass at
what you're doing and for those of you
out there on the front lines like I said
to be aggressive the best way to
mitigate risk on the battlefield is to
be aggressive do not be reactive step up
and get after it
and by the way to all you active duty
folks thank you for what you're doing
and for the vets that are listening
thank you for what you did next up I got
a question from Paul wet kick and it
says unfortunately this is to Tim I
guess unfortunately you Rogen and Harris
all pussy-footed around him I realize
he's probably into an intimidating
presence but ask him how he feels about
killing people especially possibly
innocence and don't let him use the
doing my job
bad guys collateral damage narratives
ask him how he feels about it he's
intelligent enough to cope with being
pressed for an authentic answer so Paul
wants to know about killing people and
possibly killing innocent people and
what that's how I feel about that so
first of all the nature of war is death
nature of war is is killing that is what
war is and of course there's all kinds
of other components to war there's
economic and cultural and diplomatic and
strategic but at its fundamental core
war is about death and war is about
killing and in the question here I'm
told I'm not allowed to use the
narrative of doing my job but there's a
reason why that narrative exists because
death and killing actually is the job of
a soldier and we trained for that job
and when the time comes we do our job
and we are good with it now part of that
comes from the training and part of that
also comes from the dehumanization of
the enemy yes that is a true statement
the enemy becomes dehumanized to the
soldier that's one of the reasons why
soldiers are generally okay with it and
in the past the military had to help
that process along they had to help the
soldier dehumanize the enemy and it
still does do that to some extent but I
think in the wars that we are in now we
don't need any help
dehumanizing the enemy the enemy
dehumanizes himself
you see we in the military we witness
what they do we see what they do we see
the results of the torture and the rape
and the murder
we see families beheaded
we see people skinned alive we see young
people kids kids forced to carry out
suicide bombings and now with the
internet in action the whole world can
see the completely despicable and brutal
behavior of these subhuman savages
burning people alive throwing people
from buildings drowning people in cages
ten-year-old sex slaves
it's absolutely disgusting and abhorrent
and I will tell you that I have no
problem whatsoever killing all these
vile creatures all of them
now you also asked about killing
innocents killing innocent people and as
I already stated the nature of war is
death and in war innocent people
sometimes are killed then you want to
know how I feel about it
well it is horrible it is horrible it is
awful when it does occur and yes it does
occur then let me tell you that America
goes through great lengths extreme
lengths and in doing so incurs
incredible risk to prevent killing
innocent people on the battlefield when
I fought with the 1/1 ad in the battle
Ramadi in 2006 the entire strategy the
entire strategy was developed to
minimize not only the killing of
innocent people but also to minimize the
amount of infrastructure that was
destroyed so the buildings and the power
and the water all that and again
American troops took incredible risks
incredible risks to mitigate the risks
of civilians
but war is messy war is confusing war is
imperfect war is hell and despite all
the efforts that we make despite all the
good intentions and the precautions and
the planning sometimes innocent people
are killed and it's horrible
that's horrible for the family of the
slain and it's horrible for the military
man that pulled the trigger or dropped
the bomb or through their grenade it's
horrible for the mission because in
places like Iraq and Afghanistan we are
there to protect the local populace so
it takes us backwards strategically as
we try to win the hearts and minds of
the people
but you know what it doesn't defeat us
it doesn't beat us and it doesn't even
turn the local populace against us and
I'm speaking now from my experience in
the battle Ramadi and let it be
perfectly clear that the local
population in Ramadi absolutely wanted
us there they wanted us on the ground in
their neighborhoods they wanted us to
help them get rid of the insurgents that
were terrorizing them literally
terrorizing them
and when innocent people were killed for
whatever reason we apologized and we did
what we could to help and we met and we
broke bread and we explained what had
gone wrong and we asked what we could do
to help and we paid them money and we
help them repair their buildings we did
whatever we could and I will tell you
and this never gets represented in the
press but most of the time the local
populace they understood they understood
it was a war they understood it was a
war against evil and they understood
that that meant violence and they
understood that in our efforts to help
them get rid of the cancer that ravaged
their city well they understood that
there would be bloodshed in removing
that cancer war is hell it is best to be
avoided at all costs so that innocent
lives are not lost but sometimes war
cannot be avoided and sometimes war
should not be avoided
sometimes in order to protect the
innocence war is the only choice and I
am thankful that there are men and women
in the military that have the courage
and the strength and the moral fortitude
to stand up and face evil and to also
withstand the awful burden of killing
and of death now I think this is the
last question here this question came
from Andy Vaz Lee it says what are the
biggest lessons learned from jiu-jitsu
that transcend the art of fighting
itself and can be applied to being an
effective leader so I'm a practitioner
of jiu-jitsu and it is a that's pretty
incredible it's a pretty incredible
thing to Train and for those either
trained jiu-jitsu you know what I'm
talking about
for those II that don't trained
jiu-jitsu go train jiu-jitsu because
there's so much to be learned from
jiu-jitsu about leadership and about
life I mean for instance I talked about
discipline a lot today in jiu-jitsu
you're going to learn about discipline
because it takes discipline to get on
the mat day after day week after week
month after month year after year and
you won't always feel like training as
fun as jiu-jitsu is there going to be
days you don't feel like training but
you have to find the discipline and you
have to do it so you're going to learn
about discipline in jiu-jitsu you're
also going to learn about humility
because in jiu-jitsu you will get
humbled
you will get beat by people that are
smaller than you and weaker than you and
they will smash you they will literally
submit you and that is humbling and
there is no escaping it and those those
are very important because like I said
I've said this before is that those are
lessons that some traditional martial
arts would try and teach you almost as
theoretical lessons you know like you
you must be disciplined they'll tell you
that in theory but in jiu-jitsu like I
said without without discipline there's
no there's no progress in in a
traditional martial art they'll say oh
you know you must be humble like I said
in jujitsu you actually get humbled so
jiu-jitsu teaches you a lot about life
and that's one of the things that make
it's it's so powerful in it as the
question back to the question was what
does it teach you about leadership it
absolutely teaches you some key things
about leadership and I'll give you a
couple of the most important elements
first of all detachment and I've
mentioned this word a couple times today
in jujitsu I'll tell you right now if
you let your stuff self start to get
frustrated or you let yourself start to
get angry or just emotional in general
you will start to make bad decisions and
when you start to make bad decisions
that is the beginning of the end so you
have to be able to detach from that
emotion that frustration and you got to
focus on doing the right thing at the
right time it's absolutely necessary and
that's the same thing in combat
leadership position or in any leadership
situation you cannot get caught up in
all the chaos and all the mayhem you
can't let your emotions get older you so
you have to be able to detach from that
you have to be able to step back and
breathe and see the full picture of what
is happening without the cloud of
emotion and all that mayhem obscuring
your vision
so that you can make good decisions and
jiu-jitsu will teach you to do that
now another piece of jiu-jitsu that
transfers directly into into leadership
is the idea of indirect warfare right so
in jiu-jitsu the whole premise is to
attack the weaknesses of your opponent
you don't want actor strengths you want
to attack I mean just fundamentally you
you attack the weak areas of their body
like the joints or the neck you're
you're not attacking the strongest parts
of their body and if you attack where
your opponent is strong so if you have a
ponent that's very good at defending one
type of one position or one type of hold
you're just going to wear yourself out
is if you're attacking that eventually
you're going to run out of energy and
then they're going to get the advantage
so you can't just attack the strengths
you have to attack the weak points in
jiu-jitsu and now on top of that you
also have to distract your opponent
and you have to make them defend some
area so you might maybe attack one area
so that they put their defenses there
but it's just a feint because what
you're really gonna do is you're gonna
go in attack an area where they're not
defending you're going to attack their
weak areas and it's the same thing with
leadership and a coup the clearest
example of where this is directly seen
in leadership is when you're dealing
with people's Keigo's so you take a
person that has a big strong ego you
don't attack that ego head-on that will
just make that person get ultra
defensive if you attack their ego
they're gonna get defensive immediately
now you've built up now you can have a
even harder fight so what you do is you
bypass the rego maybe you even massage
their ego a little bit so that they let
down their guard so that they let you
into their head a little bit and then
tactically and quietly you sneak in and
you plant the seeds of what you're
trying to get them to do of where you're
trying to lead them and soon enough
without seeing that those seeds are
going to grow and your idea and your
plan and your leadership comes to
fruition and that is indirect warfare
and it's the same thing in jiu-jitsu
it's the same thing in business and it's
actually the same thing on the
battlefield as well we don't attack
enemy strengths unless it cannot be
avoided so take up that jujitsu start
training and apply those lessons across
the board in your life and I think
that's I think that's it for questions
for now thanks to everybody for
listening in thanks of course to mr. mr.
Tim Ferriss for having me on tim has
been for those who don't know he's been
a huge supporter since I met him and I
really appreciate Tim everything you've
done for me and everything that's kind
of stemmed from that has been has been
awesome the interaction from everybody
through
through social media and Twitter and
Facebook and all that and everyone
that's listening and giving me feedback
on on the podcast that I have in the
book that I wrote with my buddy laughs
and it's just awesome to connect with so
many people and it's awesome to know
there's so many people that are in the
game so many people that want to get
after it just like me looking to get
better looking to do better looking to
be better so thanks to everybody for
everything and like I said especially
thanks to Tim for uh for kicking this
whole thing off so until next time this
is Jocko oh hey guys this is Tim again
just a few more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me would you enjoy getting a short
email for me every Friday then that
provides a little morsel of fun before
the weekend and five bullet Friday is a
very short email where I share the
coolest things I've found or that I've
been pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoyed this
episode is brought to you by wealthfront
and this is a very unique sponsor
wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management
in fact some of my very good friends
investors in Silicon Valley have
millions of their own money in
wealthfront so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to then a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it
here's why the value of wealth front is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint
and little things that you may or may
not be familiar with like automatic tax
loss harvesting rebalancing your
portfolio across more than ten asset
classes and dividend reinvestment add up
to very large amounts of money over
longer periods of time wealthfront as I
mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free if you use my link wealthfront com
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on the
show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealth
fronts yet because I'm not allowed to
here's the deal they wanted to sponsor
this podcast but because of SEC
regulations companies that invest your
money are not allowed to use client
testimonials so I couldn't be a user and
have them on the podcast but I've been
so impressed by wealth front that I've
invested a significant amount of my own
money at least for me in the team and
the company itself so I am an investor
and hope to soon use it as a client now
back to the recommendation as a Tim
Ferriss show listener
you'll get fifteen thousand dollars
managed for free if you decide to open
an account but just start with seeing
the portfolio that they would suggest
for you take two minutes fill out their
questionnaire at wealth
calm forward-slash Tim it's fast it's
free there's no downside that I can
think of this episode is brought to you
by headspace more than 80% of the people
I have interviewed world-class
performers across the military
entertainment sports and beyond all have
some type of meditative practice I tried
for years and years and failed miserably
the key is making it simple and you can
dramatically improve your life in just
10 minutes a day and technology can help
you this change comes through guided
meditation and headspace is by far the
most popular app for this purpose more
than 4 million users it's meditation
made simple so what I recommend is that
you take this practice meditation which
is written thousands of years of
tradition supported by thousands of
scientific studies and try it for 10
minutes a day for 10 days that's all you
need to do you could also check out the
founder and II put it Combs TED talk
which has more than 5.5 million views
his last name is PUD di co-mvp if you
want to look that up but otherwise
download the free headspace app I have
it on my phone and begin there take 10
program for 10 days of guided meditation
completely free 10 minutes a day that's
all it takes you should give it a shot
headspace calm forward-slash Tim just go
to headspace calm forward-slash Tim
you